-Our first guest tonight is
a best-selling author,
the Emmy-winning host of MSNBC's
"All In With Chris Hayes,"
and the host
of the weekly podcast
"Why Is This Happening?"
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Chris Hayes,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-We're so close now.
The last time I was here,
I was over there
so COVID couldn't get you.
-Before we had an audience,
we went over there,
and we had very firm words
with COVID ahead of time.
We were like,
"Don't get between us."
-"Don't you dare."
We talked about this recently,
not on-camera,
but we just had the eighth
anniversary of our show.
You just had the ninth
anniversary of your show.
And it does feel like it's been
a hundred years, right?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
I mean, I think -- I think
Trump into plague into war
has been,
like, a really intense run,
I would say.
-Right, because I do think
there's this --
you know,
at every turn,
when maybe people have framed it
as "We're finally
going back to normal,"
something incredibly abnormal
and with potentially
even higher stakes happens.
-Yeah, and I think, like --
I can't tell --
I think about this a lot.
I can't tell if it's
just that I'm aging,
and the longer your life goes,
the more opportunity you have
to watch once-in-a-century
things happen.
-Yeah.
-Or we've been through
a particularly insane period.
But I remember, like,
when I was younger,
I was, like, a playwright
or I'd watch TV shows
and there would be
too much stuff happening
and some, you know,
tragedy from above,
and I'd be like,
"Aw, that's not realistic."
And now everything I'm watching,
I'm like, "Yeah,
that totally could happen.
Like, there's no plot twist,
there's no, like, you know,
deus ex machina tragedy
I'm not like,
"Yeah, that makes sense."
-That's true.
-That would definitely happen.
-You're right.
We're basically living
in a Shonda Rhimes show.
-Yes!
Just one thing after another.
-Where you're like, "How did
they come up with that?"
-I mean, I even had the, like --
I mean, the timing --
and again, like, you know,
the war,
the principal victims of the war
are the people of Ukraine,
and that will then cascade out
through the rest of the world
in brutal, brutal ways.
But I do remember
having a thought of, like,
"Alright, well,
this omicron wave --
get over that wave,
and then, you know, maybe,
just maybe [Knocks desk]
things maybe chill out
a little bit."
It's like, absolutely not.
-Absolutely not,
and the other thing,
you've covered conflicts before,
but this does seem
to have moved faster
than anything
that we've certainly dealt with
in the times
that we've been on television.
-It has moved faster.
There's a real waking-nightmare
quality to it,
partly because it's so terrible
for everyone
and no one wants it
but one person.
-Yeah.
-And you're just watching this.
We were watching it
in the run-up,
being like, "Don't do this,
do not do this,
don't do this.
This will be awful
for everyone."
And you know, it's bad for --
obviously, it's bad
for Ukrainians.
It's going to be bad
for Egyptian bread buyers.
for Russian oligarchs
whose yachts are seized.
It's going to be bad
for average Russians
who are going to have
their pensions devalued
by 50% to 80%.
It's going to be bad for NATO
and the West
as they see gas prices going --
It's bad, bad, bad in every way,
and you're just watching
this entire thing,
thinking, like, "Don't do it."
And this one person is
the only one that wants it,
and that's the person
that matters right now.
-It is shocking to think
that one person has that --
their hand on a lever
that sort of contains
that much power behind it.
-It's shocking and terrifying.
-One of the things that is
different about this,
and none of us think that you
should just blindly touch --
sorry -- blindly trust
the intelligence agencies.
But, you know, obviously,
it's been a bad history,
in recent years, of the
American intelligence agency
getting things right, but
they really got this right.
And it seems like Biden
took this information
and he shared it with our allies
and, almost to the week,
got it right
that Putin was going to
actually go through with this.
-I described it
as the Iraq War in reverse,
in terms of
the public presentation
of American intelligence.
I mean, you even had
Antony Blinken,
who was sitting at the same seat
in the U.S. -- in the U.N. --
where Colin Powell
gave his famous speech,
explicitly referencing it,
saying, "I'm not here
to start a war;
I'm here to stop one."
They took a very high-leverage
strategy, which was to be
very granular
about the intelligence.
And a lot of the world didn't
want to believe it
because a lot of the world
thought this was a bad idea
and didn't want it to happen.
When it did happen
almost precisely the way
the U.S. intelligence apparatus
and the Biden administration
said,
I do think it produced
a lot of credibility
they have now leveraged
to sort of
get this coalition together.
-It is both --
Again, it goes back
to what you were saying.
I think the idea
that there's this coalition is
something
we can all be happy about.
And it does seem like
a strong -- again, early days --
strong coalition.
But it doesn't really matter
when you talk about isolating
someone like Vladimir Putin.
It seems like he's perfectly
fine, living in isolation.
-I mean, the question now is --
and then what question,
what possible off-ramp
there can be,
what possible level of pain
for the Russian government,
for Vladimir Putin personally,
for the Russian people,
for oligarchs.
What would produce a decision
that this was
not worth the price?
And right now -- I mean,
he's been very explicit.
He said the other day
something like --
the effect of, "Nothing
will ever make me back off
from the notion
that these are one people."
-Right.
-It does not sound
like a person who is ready
to get on an off-ramp.
-A lot of arguments are made
that certainly --
I don't think they're
good-faith arguments,
but people say about me,
"Why are you so obsessed
with Donald Trump?
Why are you still
talking about him?"
I imagine you get
the same sort of thing.
-We do.
-He is deeply connected
to not just the news today,
but I also think the future.
Right now,
if I had money to bet --
I don't 'cause
it's all in rubles.
I blew it.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to talk about it.
I had an investor.
-I told you
not to make that trade.
You texted me.
-I'm already regretting it.
But, you know, I believe
he will, in all likelihood,
be the Republican nominee.
-Yeah, that's the problem,
right?
I mean, if he's not the most
likely nominee for President
in 2024,
and an even-odds chance
of being the president again,
then, yeah, screw him,
forget about him.
But he is the leader
of the Republican Party.
He was a once-in-history --
He led, essentially,
a once-in-history attempt
at American democracy.
Never really happened before.
I mean, Fort Sumter, you know,
the secession.
So he is the most acute threat
to American democracy around,
and probably
in the nation's recent memory
and perhaps since the Civil War.
And he's still in power.
So he's still --
I mean, the question
about the perseverance
of American democracy
is one of the major stories
of our time,
if not the major story.
And he is the --
You know, he is the villain
in that story.
You can't not talk about it.
-We were also talking backstage
how deeply disappointing it is,
in a time where anyone would
love to have a distraction,
that Major League Baseball --
we're both baseball fans --
is currently in a lockout.
You grew up in New York,
but your dad raised you
a Cubs fan.
-Yep.
-Because he was from Chicago.
You threw out a first pitch.
How did your first pitch
at Wrigley go?
-It went very well.
-Really?
-Yes.
-Alright.
I said that in a way
that I'm already regretting.
[ Laughter ]
Now, slow down, here.
-Well, let me say,
it was not a strike,
but it was not --
it was a ball near the zone.
-Gotcha.
-Okay?
-Like, the umpire would have
had to make a call?
-Yeah, right.
I wasn't bouncing it up there.
-Yeah.
-I got advice --
I ran into Bill Murray
in a restaurant,
the summer before
I threw out the first pitch.
-Fantastic.
-Amazing.
Definitely struck up
a little conversation.
He had thrown out a first pitch.
And the last words he said to me
were, "Aim high."
'Cause you don't want to
bounce that thing.
You'd rather sail it
than bounce it.
So I aimed high, and,
yeah, it was super fun.
Have you done the first pitch?
-I did the first pitch
at Fenway Park.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
I wish I'd run into Bill Murray.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, did you, like,
50 cent it?
-No, it was perfectly fine.
I had Billy Miller,
who played for both
the Cubs and the Red Sox --
he actually did me a solid.
He went out and caught it.
So I actually had an active
player on the roster,
catching it.
And he did me a real solid.
He kind of had to do this.
He went and got it
before it bounced.
-Okay.
-But it required --
-And then he framed it up?
-Oh, he brought it up.
The other thing people --
they should also tell you is,
like, almost no one
is paying attention.
Like, when you think
about every baseball game
you've gone to in your life,
they do it
like an hour and a half
before the first pitch.
-Correct.
-No one is there.
-Right.
-There's always like two guys
who are just there
to make you feel bad.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, they, like,
show up early
just to, like, heckle.
-You basically just want to stay
off a YouTube bloopers reel.
-That's it.
You don't want to be
on the 50 cent compilation.
-Right, that's true.
There's no YouTube compilation
of, like, "The Best
Celebrity First Pitches."
-None.
-They're like, "Chris Hayes!"
Wham!
[ Laughter ]
-Look at that breaking slider.
-I was lucky enough to do --
You have a great podcast,
"Why Is This Happening?"
You're doing a special series
that I was lucky enough
to be a guest on, a four-parter.
-Yeah, it's super fun.
It's called "The Future Of."
And again, I found myself --
and maybe other people
feel this way --
it is very hard to conceive of
futures that are not dystopian.
-Yeah.
-You know, like, you go back
and you look at the
Columbian Exposition
in the 1890s
or, you know, "Metropolis"
or even "Star Trek" -- right? --
these visions of
like, "We're going to space," or
"We're solving
humanity's problems."
And "The Jetsons," even,
at a cartoon level.
Like, there's no equivalent
to that now.
All we think about the future is
like "Blade Runner"
or, you know, "The Road."
-I'd give anything for
"Blade Runner."
-That would be
a huge improvement.
-Oh, my God, if we could
get "Blade Runner"?
If my kids could grow up
in a "Blade Runner" world,
based on how things are going,
I'd be so happy.
-I guess that's a best-case
scenario at this point.
So, yeah, we're just
doing this series
and sort of looking at
the future of different things
and thinking about how --
I think particularly
because we're coming out of
this two-year period
in which everything changed,
I'm really obsessed
with, like, what stays
and what goes.
You know, your shirts,
for instance --
those are staying.
-They're staying for now.
-We're carrying that forward.
You know, the audience is back.
-The audience is back.
-We like having them back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So there's some good.
-Pandering.
Pandering also.
-Yeah, pandering is back.
-Pandering is back.
So, yeah, we've got
some cool folks
talking about everything
from the future of energy
to the future of friendship
to the future of entertainment
with you.
-Alright, well, hey,
thank you so much
for being here.
You guys, that's Chris Hayes.
-Great to be here.
-"All In With Chris Hayes"
airs weekdays at 8:00 p.m.
on MSNBC.
New episodes of
"Why Is This Happening?"
are released on Tuesdays
and available
wherever you get your podcasts.